ran for governor of California I got
three and a half million votes which is
kind of interesting because I didn't
make the first debate stage and the
whole point behind having criteria is to
make sure that anybody that falls up a
mirror who thinks he wants to run
president can't demand a spot on the
debate stage and I get that but I ran
for governor got three and a half
million votes
there were 46 people who wanted to
replace Gavin do some I finished number
one of the of all the other replacement
candidates I got 49 of the total vote on
the replacement side the next highest
person and they were independent
Republicans and Democrats that ran next
highest person got nine percent the
highest Republican after me got seven
percent
and then I got in with just eight weeks
left in eight weeks I raised 27 million
dollars 150 000 individual donors half
of them came from outside of California
uh California had 58 counties on the
replacement side I carried 57-58 and by
the way I wasn't the state party person
that they wanted they wanted a guy named
Kevin Faulkner he's a two-term mayor of
San Diego the National Party won at
Faulkner
Uh Kevin McCarthy told all the
Republicans in the house in California
to stay out of the race unless it was
Kevin Faulkner I carried San Diego
County by 30 points and I thought at
some point when it was obvious I was the
guy the base wanted that the national
and state party would either endorse me
or give me some verbal support or give
me some money they didn't either
so so why do you think they didn't is it
because I was I wasn't the guy uh I
wasn't establishment I was I was
complete complete total Grassroots I
mean I never ran for anything I didn't
think I was going to get into the race
the others had been running for months I
got in the last minute and I I went to
the top right away I mean you said it so
fast as if it's a you know not a big
deal 27 million dollars eight weeks 150
000 donors 50 right not in the state of
California and and by the way there was
a recall election in 2003 in California
that's how Gavin uh that's how uh Arnold
Schwarzenegger became Governor since
then there are five percent more
registered Democrats in California
there are 33 percent registered fewer
registered Republicans and 50 more
registered Independents and Independence
and California vote Democrat so with the
battlefield far more daunting I did just
as well as Arnold Schwarzenegger he got
49 I got 49 why do you think it wasn't
even close and uh Newsome won it and it
wasn't even like a congress it was 61 63
ended up being sixty percent what do you
think I got outspent about ten to one
and for a while the recall part was in
the margin of error and they were scared
bleepless in came Obama in came Joe
Biden in came all the money teachers
union and they turned it around and he
ended up keeping his job pretty
comfortably however he had to spend 50
more to return to retain his job than he
did to get his job
um but they turned into a national race
they said uh if you watch the
commercials
and I can count the ridges on my
thumbnail because of it I I've taken one
picture with Donald Trump both of us
have our thumbs up so every commercial
was a picture of Elder and Trump side by
side with our thumbs up and the line was
always the same stop the Republican
takeover
nobody said Gavin Newsom is doing a
great job the way he shut down the state
in a more severe way than anybody else
Gavin do some throwing a great job on
education doing a great job on budget on
crime on homelessness that never said
that they just said stop the Republican
takeover and Republicans are outnumbered
in California three to one and that's
all they had to do
there hasn't been a republican who's won
Statewide in California in 20 years
Tom I think there's something else too
it's very very interesting is as you
were rattling off those it's because you
know them by heart but I think they're
really for people listening there needs
to be kind of a more of an understanding
here there were four uh individuals that
were in the top four including two
Democrats to be the replacement
candidate
um uh which you're talking about the
number two guy Uh Kevin pavreth was a
Democrat he was a guy with nine percent
so there was people in California that
wanted this Dem to replace Gavin Newsom
and when you're talking about 3.5
million votes hats off to you for that
but when it came for the recall you got
4.9 million votes it was 38 percent in
favor of the recall and you were and you
were the recall candidate so and the
other thing I looked at I want to know
what you thought about it you just
talked about that they put you with
Trump and it was defeat trumpism and all
that but they also kind of turned it
into a mono topic election it was all
about covet this is a matter of life and
death was actually a coveted ad that
they spent more air time on than any of
the other ads even on the you and Trump
so they created this scare element is
that how you read part of it they said
that I was anti-vaccine uh even though
I've been double vaxxed you said that
you said you had been back yeah but by
opposed mandates I oppose the uh the
mass mandates I oppose the vaccine
mandates I oppose the shutdown so that
translated into Elder is anti-vax CNN
interviewed me for about a half hour
and uh I told them that young people are
not likely to get covet they're not
likely to get really sick they're not
likely to be hospitalized not likely to
die but that's not true according to the
CDC blah blah blah turns out of course I
was right yeah uh nobody said I said
they were nobody apologized the other
thing though that happened in this one
as opposed to 2003
in 2003 the Democrat lieutenant governor
ran on the replacement side as well and
that took a lot of the vote away from
Gray Davis the then incumbent so they
didn't want did not want to repeat that
same mistake there was some rumor that
the two-term former mayor of La Antonio
villarregosa a Democrat was going to run
on the placement side and I heard that
they made some sort of deal so he
wouldn't do it had he been in that race
uh it would have been a different
different ball game they paid his prior
campaign debts was one of the rumors
that's what I heard but by the way I
wasn't going to repeat that thank you
for doing that do you regret getting
that yeah
don't sue me are you at this point do
you regret getting vacs or no you're
fine with the decision if I had to do it
over again I wouldn't have done it you
wouldn't my doctor told me I I am over
65 years old I'm 71 I know look good
black don't crack
uh I'm over 65 I have high blood
pressure and I have a rare blood uh
condition and so because of these
comorbidities are as they're called he
strongly recommended that I get
vaccinated looking back at it I I think
that and I did get covet after getting
vaccinated I think I would have been
just fine so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]